Narrator:
This is the Shark Tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-Lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes of
getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
Do you see
adults wearing this?
Absolutely.
To date, we have
$9.3 million worth of sales.
Herjavec:
What?!
whoa!
They don't look
so stupid now.
Narrator: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll
walk away with nothing.
I hate this product.
Oh, my gosh.
People are calling me
all the time, "Can you send --"
they don't want it!
They're not buying it!
They are buying it!
You've got to wake up
and smell the bankruptcy, okay?
[ laughter ]
Narrator: If the sharks
hear a great idea...
reow!
Narrator:
...they're ready to invest...
Oh, wow!
...using their own money.
I want 50%.
Narrator: And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece
of the action.
This greedy Savage --
His deal is horrible.
O'Leary: He's never done
a deal like this.
Excuse me.
I'm the man.
And I want you and I
to de-Bone this pig together.
[ laughs ]
and then what -- what would you
see for the brand itself?
Money.
Narrator:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-Made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went
from waiting tables in manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-estate empire.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu,
with over $6 billion
in retail sales to date.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his
first internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban -- notorious
billionaire entrepreneur,
tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
is a fashionable way
to bring out your inner animal.
What's up,
sharks?
My name is
Alexander Mendeluk.
I'm Marley Marotta.
And we are the co-creators
of Spirithoods.
We're seeking $450,000
for a 15% stake in our company.
Our product brings the
adventurous spirit of the wild
into everyday life
while helping to protect
endangered animals.
Reow!
That happens every time
you wear a spirithood.
[ laughter ]
Can we see
that demo again?
John: Very nice.
But we're more
than a hat company.
We're
a lifestyle brand.
And as a brand, we're about
community, self-Expression,
and just all around
having a good time.
We have products for adults,
kids, and sports markets.
This is
a traditional spirithood.
It has paws
for your hands...
Cuban:
[ laughing ]
Corcoran:
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, yeah.
...sleeves that can
be turned into a scarf.
John:
Oh, my God.
Ooh, nice, thank you.
It can worn up,
it can be worn down.
There's also a button here
to secure it to your head.
And then,
on the inside,
there's a hidden
secret zipper pocket.
That Hood actually has built-In
machine-Washable speakers.
So all you have to do
is pull your phone out,
you just pull the cord out
right here,
press play, and you've
got music in your head.
Wait, wait.
I'm chopped liver?
[ whistles ]
introducing,
ladies and gentlemen,
the era
of the new fanimal.
Picture in the stands
30,000 fans
All rocking
their team Spirithoods.
I'm not feeling
this one.
So the team spirithood
line is --
is our latest addition
to the company.
Do you see
adults wearing this?
Absolutely.
Absolutely. Um --
the bulk of our sales
are to adults.
I don't care who buys them.
What are the sales?
To date, we have
$9.3 million worth of sales.
Yeah! That's
what I'm talking about.
What?!
whoa!
Corcoran: Unbelievable.
Good for you guys.
Come on!
You got to be kidding.
Marotta: 100% fact.
They don't look
so stupid now.
No.
No, they don't.
We launched the product
in 2010 at magic trade show.
We opened about
35 different Accounts
both domestically
and internationally, and --
any of
the major accounts?
We are currently in Zappos,
Nordstrom's online, in Harrods,
we've been carried
in Fred Segal.
And is this
a seasonal sales
that build around
Halloween or Christmas,
and then you kind of tail off
the rest of the year?
Well, the cold --
The cold-weather months
are our months.
So, basically,
we do 70% of our sales
from September
through December.
What is the price?
What is the price
for an average --
So, for a-a-a basic hood
like that,
our price point
is $99.
$99?
John:
That's a lot.
Now, these -- These
are synthetic, correct?
These are all faux fur.
So if this sells for $99,
what does it
cost you to make?
On average, it costs
about $29 to produce.
Wow.
That's made -- Made
in Los Angeles.
Mendeluk:
Yeah.
Great margin.
What were your sales
last year?
I know that you did $9 million
over three years.
What were they last year
and the year before?
The first year, we had
$1 million that we launched,
and the second year,
we had $4.5 million in sales.
And then the third year,
we had $3 million.
Oh. Ooh.
Hmm.
And we're on track
to do $3 million again.
O'Leary: What happened?
What happened?
We had a big explosion,
a lot of early adapters,
and then after that, we were
left with a core business,
which has
basically petered out
about $3 million
steadily every year.
Do you think it's a fad?
Is that why?
No, I think that --
I think that --
Well, of course
it's a fad,
but -- but -- but how
do you replenish it
and refresh this, right?
It was a trend
within the contemporary
women's fashion market, yes.
But, again,
we expand --
Many different markets,
into
but we have a core business
that was left from that
that followed
the brand,
because they love
what we stand for, what we do.
You never finished off
your profitability.
You did $4.5 million
your best year.
How much did you make
that year?
So the year where we made
$4.5 million,
we actually had $914,000
worth of profit.
John: Wow.
And what about last year
at $3 million?
Last year at $3 million,
we actually had a --
we had -- We ran into
some challenges,
and we had
a $500,000 loss.
John: Mm.
Whoa.
Corcoran: Wow.
$500,000
or $600,000 loss?
Herjavec: Why?
Sounds like
you got skinned that year.
[ laughs ]
Yeah, yeah.
We got skinned for sure.
We hired
a lot of people
because we wanted
to expand
into all these
different markets immediately.
We started
branching into apparel.
You're hot.
You want to go with it.
John: Yeah.
We went --
We went -- and We went
too big
for our own britches.
But what we've now done
is cut our costs,
focused on what we do best,
which is this,
and, you know,
you had mentioned that,
okay, it's
a downward trend.
Well, actually,
our online sales this year
are stronger
than they were last year.
However, we do see
a lot of potential for growth.
We just realized
that we'd need
to lock
what we do best first.
Somebody must've knocked
you guys off, right?
Many.
Marotta:
Uh, yeah. There was --
Yeah, y-Y-You've probably seen
quite a few of them
out in the market
right now.
I've seen
a lot for kids.
Yeah.
But one of the main
things, again, I want to
get to is the reason
why we've sustained,
kind of, the storm
is because of the brand,
the brand, the brand.
We have people
who've literally
tattooed our logos
on their bodies.
And I'm saying
multiple.
Like, that's how fanatic
our -- our tribe is.
I've never seen a product
that elicits a response
like this.
That --
People are literally
wanting to pet you,
take pictures with you,
they want to --
that -- that is
a big factor of this product.
Yeah.
It's the only thing
you could walk into a bar
and girls come up to you
and start petting you.
And what do you want to use
the $450,000 for?
We could stay
right now
with a viable
$3-million business,
pay off Our debt
next year,
have maybe about $500,000
in profit,
but what we really want to do
is we want to grow the company.
The teams line we see as
one of the main places
for large potential.
Guys, let me
take a shot at it.
I look at it as an interesting
fashion statement,
but it's not proprietary --
Anybody can do it.
It scares me to see a year
$4.5 million down to $3 million,
and then you're gonna
build it up in a new Category.
Look, I'm not gonna take
the ride with you. I'm out.
Good business, guys.
I mean, great answers
to all the questions.
You really look like a shark
right now, Robert.
[ laughter ]
Herjavec:
I love how you came up with it,
but I actually invested
in a company
that made really cool things
like this for helmets.
Mm-hmm.
And here's
what happened to us.
Two years,
we were on fire...
and then the sales
went completely away.
Mm-hmm.
That worries me about it, but
there's nothing wrong with that.
There's nothing wrong
with starting a business,
taking out
a whack of cash...
Mm-hmm.
...and then
starting something else.
Mm-hmm.
I'm out.
Thank you.
You look good in it.
[ Laughter ]
can I keep it?
Absolutely.
Corcoran: I think
the best use of it,
you mentioned earlier,
is as a chick magnet.
You walk into a bar
with that on,
I'm gonna go over to you and
think you're an adorable guy.
[ purrs ]
I'm not sure
I'm gonna want to date you...
wow.
...but it's
a great chick magnet.
It really is.
But you know what?
I like to buy into businesses
that are rising, not falling.
So I'm out.
Yeah.
All right, thank you.
Thank you.
There are
millions of people
who haven't seen
the product yet,
and that's one of the reasons
why we're here.
Guys, you've got
a nice little business, right?
But the thing
about it is, I --
It's too expensive
for me to sell.
What would be a good price point
for you?
$19.95.
Then maybe I could sell
a couple hundred in the Arena,
and you'll see
some folks walking around.
And I-I don't think
you can get the price point
where I can help you
in sports,
and I just don't see it,
so I'm out.
And you're left with the only
shark that matters in this case.
[ laughter ]
Daymond is still here.
Thank you for the pressure,
Rob. How --
Herjavec: Bang.
And he loves
this kind of stuff.
How colorful.
Daymond, the fashion guy
who started with hats.
Did he
say that?
I know!
John: I did.
Oh, we know that.
We've done
our research.
Yeah, yeah.
You know, and I would like
to draw a comparison,
because you know what it's like
to have an idea
and see something
in the market
and pound the streets,
put it on your friends.
You know, we did
the same type of thing.
We got celebrity exposure.
The brand grew.
We've been on Bruno Mars,
Snoop Dogg, ke$ha, Kardashians,
Justin Bieber --
The list goes on.
Here's the --
the bigger problem.
This brand
and this -- this category
are hot for a second,
is down-Trending.
I would have to take
a gamble with you,
and it would be --
it would be --
Let's take a risk.
Let's do it together.
Well, I don't know if you'll
want to take the risk with me,
because my risk
is gonna be $450,000,
and we're gonna license
this thing out, and I want 50%.
50%.
Ba-bam.
Whoo-Wee!
Narrator:
Four sharks are out.
Marley and Alexander
have an offer from Daymond,
but it's an aggressive one.
I would have to take
a gamble with you,
and it would be --
it would be --
Let's take a risk.
Let's do it together.
Well, I don't know if you'll
want to take the risk with me,
because my risk
is gonna be $450,000,
and we're gonna license
this thing out, and I want 50%.
50%.
Ba-Bam.
Whoo-Wee!
Yeah, I want to license out
all categories,
and the pricing
will have to come down.
I want outerwear, backpacks,
and we want to try to find
licenses for that
and get that out there
to support the brand.
You see, when I first started
making hats,
the hats only lasted,
literally, a year.
Other than that,
I had to move
into outerwear and t-Shirts
and Denim and everything else,
because the hats
were in and out --
they were gone.
Yeah.
And then what -- what would you
see for the brand itself?
Money.
[ laughter ]
Guys, you've got a really nice
warm and fuzzy offer here.
That's not
a warm and fuzzy offer.
Yes, it is.
$450,000 cash.
You know
what it's missing?
Barbara,
shut your pie hole.
You know what it's --
Barbara's not in this!
Barbara is not in this.
You know what it's missing?
It's missing any promise,
any conciseness of how much
he expects to make for you.
He hasn't given you
a single number.
He risked $450,000!
And yet he wants --
if he's so good
at what he's doing,
he should be able
to give you
an estimate
of what he's gonna bring in.
You're not even in
on this deal!
That's why
I'm speaking honestly.
Can we have a moment to go back
and talk for a little bit?
Two seconds?
You know what happens when you
go back and talk, right?
What happens?
You get eaten alive.
Bad things happen.
[ chuckles ]
You know,
you've watched the show.
People have left
that carpet --
don't worry about it.
Leave the ladies here,
and go ahead out.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
So, $435,000.
And he's gonna license it out
into everything else,
and then who knows
what's gonna happen
to the brand name?
Do we want him
to just take our brand
and license it out
to all these different people?
I actually thought
that was a good offer.
O'Leary: That's
a very reasonable offer.
Hey, it's a gamble.
Yeah.
It's a gamble for them,
not for you.
Why? Are you kidding?
It's a big gamble
for him.
Why is it not for me?
It can easily go to zero.
Sales are going way down.
Yeah, this thing goes to zero,
I'm out of $450,000, Barbara.
You don't think
that's a gamble?
So, Marley and Alex,
your sales went down.
You scared most sharks away
except for Daymond,
who knows
your industry...
except he wants, for $450,000,
50% of your business.
What are you going to do?
We're not prepared to evaluate
our company that low,
but what
we are prepared to do
is give a $2 million evaluation
for 22.5%,
but then a particular percentage
on licensing deals
that you bring
into the situation.
Okay, well, I mean,
that's the beauty of the tank.
When you go out to think,
I start to think,
and I already have
buyer's remorse,
and I didn't even buy it.
So I wasn't ready
to renegotiate the deal.
I'm out.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
We appreciate
the opportunity.
Appreciate it.
Good luck, guys.
Yeah, take it easy.
Herjavec:
Thanks, guys.
Mendeluk: I'm actually stoked
that we didn't go that low
and that we still have
our company to show for it.
Absolutely. 100%.
So, good work, dude.
Man: Joining me is billionaire
entrepreneur Mr. Mark Cuban.
[ cheers and applause ]
Let's give it up
for Daymond John.
Cuban: We're at
the kingonomics conference
in celebration
of entrepreneurship
and the 50th anniversary
of the Martin Luther King
March on D.C.,
and it's a unique opportunity
for Daymond and I
to help minority entrepreneurs
understand the American dream
and get fired up
about starting companies,
running companies,
and hopefully making some money.
Information
is the most valuable commodity.
The kingonomic conference
aims to give entrepreneurs --
Primarily
minority entrepreneurs --
access to capital
and information
on how to build
a successful business.
I'm somebody who benefited
off of supporting
of minority entrepreneurship,
and now I can help others.
[ cheers and Applause ]
Daymond,
thank you.
Woman: welcome to
"Shark Tank" Casting.
Thanks for having us here.
Cuban:
Maybe not everybody knows --
the sharks have nothing to do
with who comes on the show.
All we really know
is their first name
when they walk
into the Shark Tank.
So, tell me Real quick --
What's the name of your company,
how much are you looking for?
Salvers: We are here
at the kingonomics conference.
We're looking
for great businesses,
great products,
great ideas for "Shark Tank."
If you had the restroom kit,
you have everything you need
right in your hand.
Cuban:
You know, on "Shark Tank,"
we like to talk about,
"Oh, it's all about the money,"
but it's not always
about the money.
There's so many different ways
to impact the world,
and if we can give someone
the confidence
to have their dreams come True,
then it's a good day,
and we've accomplished
something to be proud of.
John:
Entrepreneurship resonates with
minorities for many reasons,
but the good thing is there's
no color when making money.
And everybody can be a part
of the American dream.
Narrator: Next into the tank
is a high-tech way
to transport you
to an alternate reality.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Jan Goetelvk.
I am from Houston, texas.
Our company is Virtuix,
and we are seeking
$2 million in exchange
for 10% of our company.
This is the Omni --
The first-Ever
virtual-Reality platform
that allows you to be
truly a part of the video game.
The Omni is
an Omnidirectional treadmill,
but we removed
all the moving parts.
It's basically
a low-friction surface
on which the user walks
with these special shoes
that have
a low-friction sole.
Steve will also
put on a support belt,
which provides safety.
You can't fall
on the Omni.
Also provides some support
so you can use
the Omni hands-free
so you can hold a controller
or a gun in your hands.
The Omni can be played
with Any existing game
that uses keyboard input.
Once you're in the Omni,
you can put on
the virtual-reality glasses.
Oh, cool.
This is right up
your alley.
The Omni enables you
to walk...
run...
jump...
and crouch
in 360 degrees,
and put your mind and your body
into the video game
to transport you
into a different world.
[ gunfire, explosions ]
Cuban: Cool.
John: Wow.
Virtual reality
has never broken through
because the technology
wasn't ready.
That's
all changing now.
The technology is here,
the Omni is here,
so which of you sharks
want to be on the forefront
of this
virtual-reality revolution?
Robert, you look excited.
Would you like to try it out?
I'd love to try it out.
Absolutely.
Whose glasses
are you using?
Goetelvk: This is
the Oculus Rift.
Okay, so you're
using Oculus Rift, right.
Oculus Rift --
You can interface
with the different types
of video platforms.
That's right.
Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
Goetelvk: Be careful, Buddy.
Be careful when you get in.
You better give Robert
a vomit bag.
[ laughter ]
All right.
Now, I'm gonna set up
the kinect.
What's it like
in there, Robert?
It's very cool.
So, Robert,
the gun is just a trigger,
so you aim
where your look.
And there's a --
Oh, very cool.
[ gunshots ]
Oh, wow!
Oh, Gee!
Cuban:
Run, gerbil, run.
Look,
he's back in Croatia!
[ Laughter ]
Kevin, come out and play.
Kevin!
[ Laughter ]
Corcoran: All right.
Oh, what a relief. My God.
It's very cool.
Feels very, very immersive.
How much is it?
Goetelvk:
We're selling those on our
website right now for $499.
That's it?
Mm-hmm.
That's cheaper
than I would've thought.
How many
have you sold?
So, we launched this product
on kickstarter in June.
What did you raise?
We raised $1.1 million.
Wow.
How many units
are you gonna have to deliver?
Close to 3,000.
Thank you very much, Jan.
That was awesome.
Great.
It was very cool.
Very, very cool.
Wait till you see
how uncool you looked up there.
John: Were you winded
when you were on there?
Herjavec:
I was, but I don't know
if I was winded because I didn't
know how to use it.
I think once you got used to it,
you'd be fine.
John: Do you think that guys
who play games like this
want to exercise?
'cause usually they have a
side job as a plus-Sized model,
most guys who are --
Who play games.
[ laughter ]
Yeah. Well, nobody likes
being overweight.
People would like to
be fit, but gamers, they
don't like to exercise.
Now we can play games
and lose weight and Burn
calories at the same time.
People are excited
about this.
Corcoran: Is that the way
you're positioning it --
as a weight-loss machine,
as well?
Is that
what you're thinking?
A-a-Absolutely.
But there's
a bigger issue, right?
This is pretty much based
around Oculus Rift, right?
As Oculus Rift goes,
you guys go.
Can you tell me what that is,
Oculus Rift?
That's the headset.
The rift
is basically what started
this virtual-reality
revolution.
Cuban: They've done a phenomenal
job of allowing you
to put on a headset
and be in an immersive world.
Is that included
in the price?
It's not included
in the price.
Herjavec: Oh, it's not?
Corcoran: So what do you pay
for that headset?
John: No, really?
$300.
Is the gun included?
The gun is off-The-Shelf.
You can buy it online.
It sounds like it's gonna be
an $800-To-$900 cost,
which is quite a bit.
Why don't you tell us why
you're worth $20 million today?
Goetelvk: Mm-hmm.
'cause, I mean,
no one's addressed that.
Herjavec:
Yeah, I want to hear that.
I think it's
the elephant in the room.
Mm-hmm.
That's a ridiculous valuation
for this.
Let me walk you
through the numbers.
The rift is an analog
for our product.
Same target market,
same people.
They're selling 200 of these
per day right now.
They project to do 500,000 units
in sales next year.
If we convert 1 out of 20 buyers
of the rift,
well, we would be selling
25,000 units next year,
which is $12 1/2 million
in sales.
Herjavec: There's a fundamental
difference, though.
When I buy the head gear,
I can still sit around
and lounge.
You're forcing me to stand,
and you're forcing me
to be interactive.
I don't think people
want to be that interactive.
I sold 3,000 units
just without a product yet.
O'Leary: Jan, staying
on the numbers for a minute,
we can debate the merits
of the product.
I'm just trying to look
at the sheer number.
You want me to pay your value
two years from now today.
Corcoran:
Here's my thinking on it.
If my husband
brought this into my house,
I would divorce him immediately.
[ laughs ]
I think it's a problem
because of its size in the home.
I also think it's a tremendous
problem to sell this in retail.
I sell a lot of product now
through retail.
I couldn't get anybody
to give the floor space to this.
You'd pay so much
just to demonstrate it.
But I think
that's a concern.
You have to realize
that 50% of the population
is married,
and they're gonna have to deal
with their wife on this one.
So I'm out.
John:
You know, I see the market.
You know,
"Black Ops" Did amazing.
"Grand Theft Auto," right?
Breaking records.
I-I see the market, but I also
don't see somebody playing this
more than an hour
or a half an hour a day
before they can't even play
it anymore 'cause they're out
of breath or they're tired.
They just won't revisit it.
So for all those reasons
and more, I'm out.
Look, great product.
I will definitely buy one.
But I think I'm an anomaly.
You'd better talk to your wife.
She's not a pushover.
Well, we have a big house,
Barbara. She'll never see it.
But I don't think that people
want to exercise
and immerse themselves in
a physical world to that degree.
I think if people really wanted
to immerse themselves that way,
I think they'll go outside.
I-I don't buy the premise.
I'm out.
O'Leary: I see
where you're going with it,
but it is a subsegment
of a subsegment market,
and it's very expensive.
I look at it and say to myself,
"is this a good deal
at $20 million
where you are right now?"
and the answer is
No, it's not.
There's too much risk
between your delivery
of a consumer product,
a retail-Distribution strategy,
and your sales.
You've got tons of risk --
All kinds of risk.
And I got to pay
Tomorrow's price today.
I hate deals like that.
I hate it
when you make me pay
for two years from now
if everything works today.
Why would I do that?
I'm not an idiot.
Because of the potential.
O'Leary:
You are going to have problems.
Poo-Poo's gonna happen,
my friend,
and I have to pay
for that now?
No. It's an outrage.
Ridiculous. I'm out.
I get what you're doing.
I could see you creating
$20 million in sales,
$25 million in sales with this,
but you're competing just like
headsets are gonna be competing,
just like the consoles
are gonna be competing.
You're one more -- one
more outlet competing
for consumer dollars.
You have to push that ball
so hard to keep going.
You haven't told me
that there's a way
to get to $50 million in sales.
And in six years,
there's gonna be
completely new technology
that blows all this away.
For those reasons,
I'm out.
Goetelvk: Thank you.
Thanks, guys.
O'Leary: Jan, you know,
I look at the experience,
and what can people learn
from what happened here today?
And, for me,
the lesson is,
very interesting I.P. --
way overpriced.
If you had put this
at a $5 million valuation,
it would've been
very interesting.
Good luck.
Thank you.
Herjavec:
Good luck, Jan.
Anybody that pays $20 million
for that is insane.
Gamers are lazy,
like most human beings.
They don't want to exercise.
No, they don't.
Narrator:
Next into the tank are two moms
from Bayonne, New Jersey,
with a cooler way
to keep kids safe.
Herjavec:
[ laughs ]
Cuban: Cool.
Cute kids.
Very cool.
Hi, sharks.
My name is Jocelyn Fine.
And I'm
Kelly Dineen.
We're
from New Jersey,
and we are the founders
and moms behind Fohawx!
We're here today
seeking $150,000
in exchange
for 30% of our business.
Sharks, just about
every parent can relate
to the struggle
that you face
when you try to get your child
to wear their safety helmet.
It's a fight.
Why?
Well, safety helmets
are not perceived as being cool.
They're clunky,
plain, boring.
So we took
something ordinary,
and we've made it
extraordinary.
Originally inspired
by my daughter Maya,
Fohawx! Are decorative, funky
foam helmet accessories
that come in a variety
of outrageous colors
and styles.
Each and every Fohawx!
Comes with its own
self-adhesive velcro strip
so it can easily be...
removed and...
reattached.
Will it work
on Kevin's head?
[ laughter ]
so you can remove it
and reattach it
to any safety helmet.
So kids
can collect them all,
or they can swap
with their friends.
The Fohawx! Brand
will continue
to design and develop
products
that get kids excited
about safety gear
because with Fohawx!,
safety has never looked so cool.
Very cool.
Together: Thanks, guys.
Say Bye to the sharks.
Good job.
Herjavec:
Bye, guys. Bye, girls.
Cuban: Bye.
Bye, kids.
Jocelyn, can we see one?
Cuban:
Yeah, could we -- can we?
Of course.
Absolutely.
Well, here's
some samples.
Corcoran:
So what is the age group
that you're targeting here?
We are targeting...
thank you.
...children between
the ages of 4 and 10.
This --
This whole concept,
like I said before,
was inspired by my daughter.
We were doing
a family bike ride,
and my son,
who was 7 at the time,
refused to wear
his bike helmet.
And my daughter,
she ran to the garage,
got some glue gun
and some purple tissue paper,
and created a mohawk
right down the center
of his helmet,
and his whole
attitude changed.
He loved it.
He thought he looked so cool.
And I loved it because
he was wearing his helmet --
No complaining.
Jocelyn, there --
There's a lot of products
like this out there.
What's different about --
Okay, what really differentiates
us is the versat--
versatility
of this project -- Product.
In what sense?
The -- the fact is that
it can attach to any helmet.
This is something that kids --
Really excite kids
because there's
sort of limitless styles
that we could come up with.
We can --
what do you make it for,
and what do you sell it for?
We make it for $5.
That's packaged and landed.
A good
price.
Oh.
Yes, and our msrp
is $19.99.
And how many have you sold?
Where have you sold them?
Since we started selling,
which was just over a year ago,
we've sold
about 5,000 units
and generated
$50,000 in sales.
How?
Um, we are in over 80
specialty retail toy stores
across the United States.
We are also in test mode
with two of the biggest
mass-market retailers
in the world --
Toys "R" Us and Walmart.
Not in retail --
Online.
Not in retail, but as some
of you probably know,
the mass-Market retailers
like to test your products
a little bit beforehand.
Right.
Online.
John:
They're gonna want --
they're gonna want this thing
at $9.99, aren't they?
Well, you know,
we have had no pushback
from any of the buyers.
They have not pushed back
on the price.
From walmart, you're saying?
Walmart has -- has not pushed
back on the price, which --
So they're okay
with a $20 retail price?
Exactly.
I don't think so.
Yeah, that's
hard to believe.
Yeah, there's no --
is there competition for it?
Sure, there is.
You kidding?
There is no --
We want to be sold --
Wait a sec.
There's tons of competition.
Kelly, there's
tons of competition.
I disagree.
If you go into
any mass-Market retailer
and walk down
the helmet aisle,
there's no
helmet accessory.
But, Kelly, if I walk
into a ski shop on a ski hill,
there's an entire rack
of stuff like this.
Okay.
Also, a bike shop.
O'Leary: There's
tons of competition.
But we want to be in every
mass-market retailer.
We're talking about Toys "R" Us,
Walmart, Target --
It's -- Yeah.
Why -- Why are your sales
so low?
$50,000, and you've got
how many stores?
In -- Low? I don't agree.
In one year in over 80 specialty
retailer stores, and we --
she's feisty.
Look at her go.
O'Leary: Yeah, we're --
We're selling --
Yeah, but we're selling --
We're two moms
from new Jersey.
Yeah, and I get it, but I'm
struck. The numbers don't lie.
You're selling hundreds of
dollars of them in each store.
We just started selling
over a year ago.
I know, but in a year,
with 80 stores,
you've done $625 per store
in a year.
They're all
gonna get delisted.
There's no way on earth
a retailer's gonna keep that in
with such small velocity.
That's tiny.
What's happening?
Well, we envision --
We envision expanding
this assortment to include
the hottest kids licenses,
animation characters --
No, but -- but
you don't have to expand.
Cuban: Yeah, you're
missing his point. Yeah,
you're missing his point.
No, no, no. You're not --
You're not going to expand.
They're not gonna
take more product.
It's not working.
It's just not working.
It's only been a year.
Give them a little break.
It's a year!
Fine: Another thing We really
need to talk about is licensing.
We think that --
what? Don't even go there.
You've sold
$50,000 worth of this stuff.
Corcoran: Yeah.
No, no. Go there. Tell me
your idea about licensing.
Why?
Because we really see that this
is -- This is what kids want.
They asked us
for this product.
They don't want it!
They're not buying it!
Maybe people
don't want to buy them.
Well, that -- We haven't
had that experience.
No, just -- That's
just not possible.
Look, you're on fire.
You're burning.
You have to figure out
what's wrong
and fix it right away
before you go to zero.
Do you think that if this
was price point at $9.99,
we would be
selling more?
I think so.
Try anything.
No.
You do? Okay.
Try anything.
So let's
make that happen.
I have to get to China.
I need your contact.
Corcoran: Kelly, Kelly, Kelly.
The only way --
O'Leary: No, no, no, no.
Can I get a word in here?
Have you ever set a price
at $9.99?
Excuse me. Excuse me.
Let's stay on the numbers.
Excuse me.
Barbara!
We were still talking, Barbara.
You're interrupting.
Excuse me.
I can't get a word in here.
I'm still talking.
You're interrupting.
Just pipe down.
No, I'm not interrupting.
I want to know one thing.
I'm getting --
I'm getting a word in.
Can I finish my --
Can I finish my statement?
You've got a minute.
Go ahead.
Have you set it up
at $9.99 or done --
Or done flash sales to see
how people respond at $9.99?
We did do
a few partnerships
with some of
the hot flash-Sale websites,
and they did sell out
and come back
and ask us for more.
There's your answer.
Was that part --
Go ahead, Barb.
Excuse me.
Can I speak a moment?
Yes.
Fine: Yes, please.
Consider the possibility
that you're blinded
by your sheer love
of Making this thing go,
which is a wonderful trait,
but not when it negates
fact that's all around you.
You've got to face the reality
that all the signs are saying,
"It's a problem, it's a problem,
it's a problem,"
but you're too blind
to see it.
So --
So what are you
gonna do, Barbara?
But I don't --
I'm out for sure.
We are absolutely --
We are absolutely committed
to making this.
That's not enough.
That's -- That's not enough.
That's not good.
Yeah, but there's --
Everybody who walks
into the Shark Tank
is fully committed.
That's why they're here.
Okay.
It takes more than that
to be successful.
We are two moms trying
to create this company.
We need somebody
who can talk to China.
We want expertise in
global expansion, licensing --
[ laughs ]
Oh, lordy.
O'Leary: Why?
They're asking for it.
We've had --
You haven't even conquered
New Jersey.
What are you worried
about the globe for?
The market
wants this now.
I hate this product.
It doesn't sell.
Fine: It's too soon.
It's too soon.
Then don't say --
Oh, my gosh.
People are calling me
all the time, "Can you send --"
why don't they buy it?
We've had
international distributors.
They are buying it!
Well, why doesn't it
show up in the numbers?
What would you -- What would --
what would've made you happy?
If we came in here and we said
we sold $75,000, $100,000?
Numbers five times this.
What are you
looking for?
Cuban:
No, actually, wait. No.
Here's what would've
made it happen.
A million dollars?
Herjavec: No, no.
This is what would've
made us happy.
If you would've said,
"We had one store,
and they sold $50,000 worth,"
and you would've said,
"We just need more money
so we can go to a second store
and then a third store."
Then we could project numbers.
You're selling us on the dream
and not discussing the green.
I'm out.
Kelly, Um, look, you're --
You're very scattered.
There's a lot of products
like it.
You don't want to acknowledge
that, but there are.
And you're not getting
enough customers.
We really feel like this is
the beginning for us.
I appreciate what you're saying,
but for us,
we really are just --
Our momentum is just
really starting now.
I hope so.
I'm out.
Okay.
Daymond,
let's do this together.
Let's -- You want
to sell them at $9.99?
Let's do it together.
It's not about the sales
that we're upset about.
It's the sales
and amount of the stores.
You have to look at that,
and you have to take
all this you've learned
and use it
moving forward.
But at this point,
I can't help you. I'm out.
Okay,
thank you.
Herjavec:
Is there anybody left?
Well, yes, there is.
Mister --
[ laughs ]
Oh, Mr. Wonderful,
I can't wait to hear this.
[ laughter ]
I don't know
what you're gonna do.
I really don't know,
because you're on the path,
right now, to zero.
Well, we came here today
prepared to make a deal,
and we are still --
This business
is not working.
There's no numbers
that make it work.
It is working.
I just gave you the math,
and you deny it.
What's the matter
with you?
Listen -- This is
the first step of Fohawx!
There will be a Fohawx!
For every single kid.
With the mavericks.
There will be a Fohawx!
With a fubu.
You can print
on this.
There's glitter,
there's die-cutting.
Okay, I can't
take it anymore.
It's endless.
Corcoran: Kelly --
I want partners
that can deal in reality.
You've got to wake up
and smell the bankruptcy, okay?
I'm out.
All right,
you're missing out.
Okay, thank you.
John: Good luck.
Good luck, guys.
Cuban: Good luck, guys.
Fine: Okay.
Thank you.
Prove us wrong.
[ sighs ]
Corcoran: Ugh.
Exhausting.
I truly feel like Fohawx!
Is my fourth child.
I have sacrificed
so much to get here,
and I'm just
really disappointed
that it didn't
come across
as being as successful
as it feels to us.
They were determined.
Ferocious,
I would say.
Blinded.
The question was, were they
determined to make money,
or were they determined
to prove themselves right?
To be right.
My name is Al "Bubba" Baker,
and I live in Avon, Ohio,
with my beautiful wife,
Sabrina,
and I have
three lovely children.
I played in the NFL
for 13 years.
I was rookie of the year.
I was an all-Pro.
That was my job then,
but barbecue is my passion.
So, how we doing over here?
Fantastic.
After my NFL career, I opened up
my own barbecue restaurant,
and that's where
my revolutionary product
was invented.
It's convenient, it's delicious,
and it's all-natural.
Here you go. You ready?
Touchdown!
It's important for us
to get this investment today,
because we've spent every penny
on this dream,
and we've almost wiped out
the profits from my restaurant.
My family's made
a lot of sacrifices,
particularly my wife, Sabrina,
and I want to be able
to show her
that at the end of the day,
it's gonna pay off.
Being in the NFL for 13 years,
things don't always go according
to your game plan,
and it's the end result --
Winning -- that matters.
Hi.
I'm al "Bubba" Baker
from Avon, Ohio,
owner of the de-boned
baby back rib steaks.
I'm seeking $300,000
in exchange for 15% equity
in my company,
and this is
my lovely daughter Brittani.
She's gonna make you sharks
ribs in a microwave
in two minutes.
Now, I played a little football
in the NFL for 13 years.
That was my job.
Barbecue is my passion.
Sadly, I married a woman
that doesn't like ribs
because they're too messy.
So I vowed to find a way
for my wife
to be able to enjoy ribs.
But how do you make ribs
less messy?
You take the bones out.
[ laughs ]
After 20 years,
I found the perfect method,
and the de-boned
baby back rib steaks were born.
We are the only people
that have removed the bones
from an actual slab of Rib,
leaving the meat intact
so that everyone can enjoy ribs
with a knife and fork.
Our de-boned baby back rib steak
is not pieces of meat
formed in the shape of a rib,
if you know what I mean.
[ laughs ]
you tell them, Bubba.
Boneless meats are
the way of the future,
and the future is now.
Make no bones about it, sharks.
It's time for some ribs.
John: Yeah.
It's always time
for ribs.
All right, Bubba. Bless me
with the Bubba baby back.
[ laughs ]
Cuban:
Bubba, who'd you play for?
Well, I played for the lions.
I was rookie of the year
in 1978.
I played for
the then-St. Louis cardinals,
and then I came back and
I retired in Cleveland in 1990.
That's a long career, man.
Great career.
This is
absolutely delicious.
Yeah,
it's very good.
This is really,
really Good.
Thank you. Thank you.
So, basically -- I just want
to be really, really clear.
I buy this, I throw it in the
microwave for two minutes --
and it tastes like this?
You got it.
Mmm.
Often, when we
go to restaurants,
cowboy rib eye,
bone-In rib eye --
Some people actually believe
that the bone
just tastes better.
That's a great point.
We cook the product
with the bone in it,
and when the product
is fully cooked,
then we remove the bones,
then we quick-chill it,
and then it's packed
right away.
O'Leary:
Is there anything proprietary
about how
you're removing the bone,
or are you
genetically altering cows
So they grow up
with no ribs?
[ laughter ]
actually, it's pigs.
Kevin, it's hogs.
Okay, So, why couldn't I
just do the same thing?
Well, um...
if you mind,
I'm not running, guys.
The process and the product --
don't run from
the tough questions.
Okay.
I'm not gonna
run from any questions.
Literally.
Right here, Kevin,
is the patent
for the product,
and right here is
the patent for the process.
Wow.
Could I see
the process patent?
Here. Take them both
to them.
So, nobody else Can make
boneless ribs?
Let me be more specific.
No one else can make
a fully cooked rib
with either one or more
bones removed from it.
Wow.
And how do you
get the bones out?
If I tell you that,
I got to kill you.
Kill him.
Cuban: No, you don't.
You got a patent.
You got a patent
for it, Bubba.
You can tell him.
Yeah, tell me.
Baker: Robert, honestly,
there's the patent,
then there's the know-How,
and what I say to people
who are gonna go try
and reverse-engineer
and figure out how to do it,
I say, "Good luck to you,
'cause it took me
20 years to do it."
O'Leary: I got to
tell you something.
In the entire history
of "Shark Tank,"
I've never seen a patent
on a food product ever before.
Thank you.
'cause we worked it.
Herjavec:
Al, what are your sales
and how many locations
are you in?
Okay, our sales
are $154,000.
Over what period?
Over a year's period.
We're selling
in about 48 stores.
You said it took you
20 years to develop this,
and you've only been
in business one year.
What happened
to those other 19 years?
Well, at one point,
I'll be honest with you.
I, um -- I hate to
use this word -- I quit.
And the reason
that this young lady and I
are partners is
we had an incident
where she was in track,
and, like most dads,
I was pushing her.
She said, "Hey,
I don't want to run track."
I said, "You cannot quit."
And she said, "Well, you quit
on the boneless ribs."
Oh!
Corcoran: Powerful.
Yeah.
If it wasn't for her,
I wouldn't still be doing
what I'm doing.
O'Leary: Okay, guys.
I actually am an investor
in a restaurant chain
with 450 locations
that sells
a ton of protein,
and this is their second-largest
selling item -- Ribs.
Here's the big problem
with your deal right now.
You're asking for $2 million
valuation on this thing.
You're not making any money.
The only value here
is in the patent.
This reminds me of a story
that's so relevant to you.
I love stories.
The first season
of "Shark Tank,"
a guy stood
right where you are.
He had
a folding-neck guitar.
He wanted to build out
a guitar company.
The only thing of value
was the patent
on the folding-Neck technology.
You know where
we are today?
Where are you at?
They are licensing
that technology
on Fender Bender guitars
all around the world.
He's gonna be rich.
Listen to
what I'm saying to you.
A patent on a food product --
That's interesting.
And the only value
in the patent
is to license it to
one of the suppliers of protein.
I want to take you
to one guy...
okay.
...that supplies eight --
You know what?
Pigs hate this guy.
[ laughs ]
All around the world,
pigs are walking around saying,
"Stop the senseless slaughter,"
because of this one guy.
[ laughs ]
So, my offer is very simple.
I'll give you the $300,000.
It's contingent on getting
one of the large
meat processors in america
to license the patent.
But I want 49%.
That's the deal.
Narrator:
All five sharks are still in.
Kevin has made an offer
of $300,000,
contingent on a licensing deal
with a large meat processor.
But he wants
49% of Al's company.
That's the first time
Kevin actually has a decent idea
when it comes to
something like this.
It's the first time
we've heard his stupid idea
making any sense.
John:
That idea is so brilliant,
I'll do the exact same deal,
but I'll only take 30%.
Bam, Kevin!
This greedy savage --
His deal is horrible.
O'Leary: He's never done
a deal like this.
If you talk to
the guy that owns --
I've licensed plenty.
Al, let me
clear it up for you.
Yeah, okay.
I think you're paying
a very expensive price
for somebody
to make a phone call for you
that you could do
on your own.
I'm out.
Barbara?
I would have pitched you
that I should bring you
to some of the big-box stores,
some of the club channels,
like B.J.'s, Costco,
but I happen to think
some of the offers on the table
are better, so I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
Cuban: I'm kind of
in the same boat.
I think you need to
fatten up the hog some
before it's ready to go.
For me, the business would
have to be a little bit bigger.
That's why you're limited
kind of to the licensing play.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
Herjavec:
Al, you got two offers.
Yeah.
Both licensing deals.
Al, is this the path
that you want to go down?
Talk to the guys
at Voyage-air and Fender --
All around the world.
I'm the man.
And I want you and I
to de-bone this pig together.
[ laughs ]
You've got the real deal,
or you've got the
discount license guy.
Day 1, you're not
taking a check,
and he wants to take
50% of your company.
49%.
I'm worth every cent
of that 49%.
What are you gonna do?
Um, Kevin, I love the fact
that you have made us an offer,
but I think I'm gonna
take Daymond's deal.
Ah!
You picked
the better man, my son.
You de-boned the pig
right in front of me!
Thanks a lot.
Right deal, al.
Thank you.
Thanks a lot.
Congrats, guys.
[ laughs ]
Hey, hey!
He was
a great salesperson.
He was a great pitcher.
Yes, he is.
He was
a great salesperson.
He understood
the art of pitching.
And he sure knows
how to cook a rib.
[ laughs ]
Yay!
Studying
Daymond's background,
I think he's a guy
that enjoys making change,
and that's what this is going to
do to the barbecue industry.
It's gonna change barbecue
as we know it.